[Music]
and sucker punch news after rain weather
I want the rain to come back it is it's
supposed to make a comeback today all
tonight was raining okay that was a
really strong wind no I checked out
cells like all my personal wishes it
sounded like wind at first I like the
rain though we've been having some good
rain like we haven't had rain like this
in over a decade I love it bring us out
of the drought a man attacked his
attorney immediately after he's given a
47 years old you like you're gonna go
into G I like God he's guilty for doing
some shin he gets pissed though like
come on man that's your fault it's good
you told me I've always seen that and
wondered that because you see like a guy
in there like we give you live life in
prison and it's like and then the lawyer
next James like that's a son of a [ __ ]
you know yeah how come the guys were
never like you [ __ ] you is your fault
man I'm sure they'd I'm sure they do I'm
sure people do that sometimes yeah but
I'm sure they're also like processing
like life in prison right true his name
is David he's 42 years old who this was
caught on camera by always with Josh
nice he pistol whipped his girlfriend
and then he set is an apartment complex
on fire that's 47 years let us all with
the dealing with attempted murder on
everyone in the [ __ ] building oh I
see yeah he got a lot of people in
danger yeah I don't see that what do you
got not have hit the [ __ ] what's
it called a lawn yeah arson or yeah I
mean I was gonna say arson and I guess
all of it I'd be so mad if you burn my
family photos Oh worry or your house
they're like I don't care about the
house to get a new one
you can't [ __ ] get new memories it's
true well my family photos are my phone
now and they're on the end the clan at
mine get put the show car do you have
all your old photos all scanned up and
ready to go no but I'm saying we should
do this yeah
yeah but what if they got BRR before you
had a chance to your right
I think 47 years is a little easy now
[ __ ] fry his brain and give him a
lobotomy so he gets his memory erased to
your dam that'd be crazy if you cut
someone's head open like this right
while they're still awake and then just
numb it and you take the top off like a
coconut they do that frying pan that's
just ready to go that's completely hot
my god I didn't kill it ago and you just
[ __ ] fries brains literally do you
think they would die probably I don't
know sure he's like your brain would
overhear you just cook like meat
think we're qualified to answer this
what a Looney Tunes kind of punishment
to stammer Franks understand why if
people act like an animal they get
treated like a human that's what I don't
understand because of cruel and unusual
punishment they're a ridiculous law it's
not cool and unusual of their cruel and
unusual a [ __ ] up here is the fact
that they handcuffed him in the front so
he did a double punch like this once
again that was quick
that was fast was that right after the
sentence that that moved fast yeah he
needs to belong in prison yeah there's a
lot of crazy people that don't really
control their selves they need to go to
jail because like living in downtown LA
I saw so much crazy so much sometimes
it's like hmm is dangerous dude imagine
being him for a second I don't know what
happened maybe his girlfriend like
[ __ ] dump dinner or some [ __ ]
probably some [ __ ] like that
he [ __ ] pistol whips her right which
is crazy already that's nothing you get
the get a pistol in the same moment he
sets fire to the buildings are here
you're here yeah and then you find out
that your life is over that's [ __ ]
crazy
you hit your lawyer he sees you and then
did not see me
Yeah right yeah [ __ ] that's crazy just
like in a day
[ __ ] her whole life up so he is
already on trial as a criminal right
he's not the person that's suing he's
the defendant right yeah
that means if that guy was one of those
free government lawyers who the [ __ ]
would want to take his case yeah now
that you know he beaten football and
football pads like boxing gearing just
like our your honor your honor my client
did not beat the other lawyer he was
just swatting a fly out of there no but
we a so the lawyer a broken nose a
possible concussion and injuries to his
face including a smaller and he had new
songs so the cuffs was the [ __ ]
assassins and they're saying like you
know I'm just glad he didn't choke me
out yeah that's crazy because that means
he has no guilt mm-hmm he just thinks
that if this guy didn't do his job yeah
if he didn't get away it's your fault
not my fault I love that yeah he could
have received more than a hundred years
behind bars so you got a discount that's
been down to 47 47 I mean most criminals
are criminals because they don't think
what they're doing is wrong he also bit
his leg what the leg of the attorney yet
oh my God we're trying to treat it like
a debutante stick that's crazy this
whole time in jail all he's gonna be
doing is just thinking about how that
lawyer [ __ ] him over in a lot of
jacking off I'm gonna library read some
erotica
sometimes it blows my mind how people
don't really see or understand any of
this stuff and they just hate cops all
day like they have to [ __ ] deal with
the dirt of the earth yeah they have to
deal with some crazy [ __ ] - have you
seen those videos where like what a
police officer has to do in a training
situation or it's like somewhat how
quickly someone can pull a gun on you
and how oh yeah [ __ ] crazy video
recently of this like cop that like
pulled over this like just using
somewhere like Sonoma County or whatever
like super split so I can't like she's
like hey roll down the window he rolls
down the window like BAM it's like
almost shoots her and then she goes
around the other side and dumps the
entire Magnum
no [ __ ] crazy you know like these
criminal logic did you guys watch the
surviving or Kelly yeah it's so good so
we have a common person knowledge right
I mean a common person like logic yeah
and then every time you cut to are
Kelly's brother that's in jail you know
he's gonna say some crazy yeah so it'll
be like people are like Manning and it's
so bad to the point where like aren't
Kelly would prey on all these women and
he even told them like I'll pay you out
if you pay it pay me if you just take
this bribe money you take a hundred
grand yeah and then it cuts to the
brother in jail that's stupid he should
have took that money every time he cut
to him you could you could just see why
people have spent a lifetime in jail why
because our logic is just so [ __ ] up
when he was like well what he said you
like you like them young what's so wrong
about that it's just the preference you
know what it is he's already in jail
what can you do to him it was like I'm
in [ __ ] jail you might as well have
an immunity card but it's funny that
like he his logic was like I don't see
what's wrong with this just crazy Wow
I'm like that's why you're inside of
there I think you should be able to
marry babies what's wrong with that
it's a preference I thought was really
strange too because he said he was
molested he was a kid right the brother
in jail yeah
but then when he was he was talking
about are Kelly coming to him to tell
him that he was molested he's like no
you weren't like how do you know no no
yeah so the one in jail never accept
anything like that it was the little
brother so the little brother entrusted
in are Kelly was getting molested and he
goes hey so and so family members
molesting me and then art Howe is like
no he's not and he was being molested by
the same one but he was in denial yes
tonight it
what's it are to Lou or some [ __ ] no
it's on lifetime anything but you can
get it on prime oh yeah that's it
look it up on I got it I'm I've been
watching this judge you guys gotta check
him out his name is like Frank Giuliani
or something like that but but okay but
it's called calm air
that's that's Rudy Julie yeah but his
name so forget the name but the show is
called talk into Providence improvident
yeah I don't want to be stereotypical
he's a Italian dude that's why I mean
yeah norther names oh yeah yeah yeah got
it he's like hella nice to all of his
people it's like the opposite from like
IMG yeah Judge Judy or whatever and in
like the people are stupid as balls but
like he helps them kind of like he's
very compassionate and he teaches them
how to like deal with you know the law
and all that stuff and there's people in
there that are self incriminating and
it's so [ __ ] funny but it's like a
different side to like judge like the
approach of how a judge cannot deal with
the community and then you feel good
after because it's like oh this guy's
[ __ ] nice what yeah he's really sweet
guy judge I don't know if I am sold on
them but it's the people that's
hilarious is the cases in each cases
because I like how Judge Judy just
[ __ ] tears [ __ ] if it gets old and
boring and then I start feeling like
like my IQ drops by listening to these
people oh yeah yeah but then in this
case it's like the way he maneuvers and
his patience and how he deals with
people it makes you feel like really
dope and he's really cool yeah yeah yeah
but I just love the type of people that
show up cuz all of the times they have
no [ __ ] clue it's almost like talking
to a six-year-old yeah but it's like a
full-grown adult and they're just like
staring at the judge with their mouths
wide open and they don't know what the
[ __ ] is going is it the typical [ __ ]
where it's like he said he was gonna
paint my house he never paint in my
house and then he showed up one day and
just did this thing with a tee with a
roller real quick and then he left it's
real cases so that stuff kind of feels a
little weird nah yeah yeah yeah this is
real like this real court this is like
traffic cases like small criminal things
or you know you know like disturbing the
peace or whatever and um there's ones
were like there'll be clear video
evidence of someone running a red light
and then the lady's like I wasn't I
wasn't I was I stopped because I have a
picture here and a picture is stopped Oh
No yeah he's like the picture you're
stopped because yes you see this photo
it's true I'm
stop but if that video I don't know what
kind of video you had but in Toulouse
she's and she didn't stop at the red
light yeah but she's like but you could
see this picture I'm styling this
picture don't move
yeah it's cuz I'm stopping you like you
see the picture that they sent me the
picture that the court your government
sent me is stopped and who's just sadi
they're cracking the [ __ ] that's
incredible dude it'd be funny if the
picture they took this snapshot while
the person was like in the middle of the
intersect yeah you see I parked yeah
yeah while I ran the red light in the
middle of the intersection that's not
their pictures they show weird video of
it - yeah she don't want to see it she
was just like I don't know what kind of
tricks you did they're so good I
remember I stopped completely and the
evidence here in the photo you sent me
I'm stopped and you so nice she was like
she's gonna charge it's like I'm not
gonna give you the ticket I'm gonna
dismiss it but not for the reason you
think is it goes why cuz I stopped
because no no no it's not because of
that it's because there's no sign that
says you can't make a right turn on red
and I guess in in in Rhode Island or
whatever you can make a right turn on a
red without stopping or depending on if
there's a sign or not so he's helping
her get away and she's still arguing
about that she stopped um but there's a
lot of cases like that and it's just
[ __ ] hilarious oh my god I'm in okay
you sold me people can't be safe
[Music]